let's talk about some um some america
so that's that's where we went there and
now we're just doing a hard segue right
to this story from cnbc wholesale price
measure rose 9.6 in november from a year
ago the fastest pace on record the pace
was even faster than the estimate 9.2
the core producer price
index increased at a 6.9 pace a bit
slower than estimates but still the
fastest ever in records dating in august
2014. of course we also have uh news i
think they bring this up here
that um for the consumer price index as
well it's also massively up so basically
long story short inflation is through
the roof
the m1 money supply uh so this is what i
did on my main channel today i pulled up
the m1 money supply
from march of 1986 when i was born
until today
from the from the day month of my birth
until the 2008 crisis the money supply
just narrowly doubled
from 800 billion to 1.6 trillion
from
that point forward we get to the
pandemic year where the money supply due
to how they track the money the savings
accounts they said now savings are
effectively checking the money supply
increased i think like five like five
times
from something like two trillion to like
16 trillion that's not two times like
eight times but i could be wrong i think
it was i think no i'm sorry five times
and uh i think it might have been three
but since then since may of 2020
we have added i think something like
four or five trillion dollars to the
money supply and now the democrats are
proposing printing another i'm sorry
reason that it's selling another 2.5
trillion joe biden puts out that video
where he's like we pay our debts in
america that's why i'm raising the debt
ceiling and it's like that's not paying
your debts that's taking out a credit
card to pay off loans it doesn't work
eventually your the debts come due and
you default
so i'll tell you this very simply put
what we are seeing now with this
wholesale price increase
it's like watching the initial tsunami
start coming in the water starts pouring
over the seawall the pandemic was when
the water line receded and all the water
went away and we're like where'd the
water go now all that water is rushing
back faster and higher than ever
and we're seeing these these signs i
have a feeling that next year is going
to be apocalyptic apocalyptically bad
and i wonder if we're entering like
weimar germany era like back in the day
during in the weimar era they were
shoveling bills like in the gutter it
was so worthless like venezuela levels
yeah in the fiat currency era in in
college they they tell you about
keynesian keynesianism about modern
monetary theory all this nonsense to
kind of cloud your brain but it's as
simple as what tim discussed a second
ago is that if you print a lot of money
the money is going to be worth less if
you print trillions of dollars there's
trillions of more dollars in circulation
and that means your purchasing power is
drastically reduced that cpi index is
actually based on a basket of goods that
isn't really
like there's other stuff in there that
can make it way higher and if you were
to calculate it
from the 80s consumer price index it
would be
almost 20 at this point inflation so
that that's the kind of numbers that
we're talking about and the idea that
like oh this is america so we're never
going to see hyperinflation that's kind
of um a dangerous um
hedge to make especially because we've
only been on fiat currency for 50 years
so you know it's already these these uh
hyperinflation incidents has happened i
think in 60 countries now since then so
the idea that it can't happen in america
is a little foolish and you you even
have jack dorsey you have twitter
openly mocking the idea that it's
transitory yeah yep
jack dorsey tweets in quotes transitory
yeah take a look at this from the m1
money supply
so a lot of people like to point out
that this major spike is a change in
reporting and we shouldn't really talk
about it which is bs it used to be that
you could only transfer out of your
savings account six times to your
checking account which meant savings
were meant to be saved well because of
the pandemic they said spend away spend
whatever you want to the money supply
immediately exploded look at this
from 4 trillion 4.7 trillion up to 16.2
trillion
however let's ignore that metric and
let's talk about the current rate of
growth in the united states
from may of 2020 we are at 16.2 trillion
today
we're at 20 trillion in october
look how much that's grown over uh
nearly four oh just about four trillion
dollars
in close to what like a year and a half
now take a look at when the mon the
month i was born march 1986
633 billion
how long did it take for that to double
really it was let's see where we go what
we're trying we're trying but it's going
down it's going up it's going down and
there we go
2003 from 1986 2003
to go up 600 billion dollars
now we're up trillions of dollars
already in the span of a year and a half
look at percentages so in a year and a
half it went up 25
basically so we've and now go back to
the date of your birth how long did it
take to get 25 to 900 up there from
wherever it was
six years six years six years so it took
us one year now a year and a half to go
up a quarter that was like 30 years ago
but you got to understand too i don't i
don't think it makes sense to go
percentage once a month i don't think it
makes sense to go percentage-wise
because as as
the money supply from 16 trillion it's
happening too fast so it's going to be
exponentially bad right the the the
effects of the mass printing of money
the trillions of dollars in spending we
are not going to feel we're not going to
feel that immediately it's going to take
time yeah so what i what i imagine is
likely going to happen is you see that
chart showing inflation there's a major
spike where it's like up to seven
percent and now the presumer uh producer
pricing index is up you know ten percent
what are we gonna hit max kaiser said we
were at 15 inflation and they're lying
yeah so that means what are they gonna
officially start reporting fifteen
percent by mid next year
i mean it's going to be the apocalypse
for the democratic party it might just
be that one day you know 10 years down
the line we'll wake up and just realize
that our purchasing power is basically
worthless under the dollar i think that
a lot of people have this image in their
heads of one day we're just going to be
weimar germany and we're going to be
shoveling stuff in wheelbarrows and
maybe that day will come but inflation
kind of like it seems to be creeping up
on us you know if it's 10 compounding 10
10 10 then your purchasing power has
been significantly reduced over five
years and i think that's the thing that
a lot of people don't see coming is this
creeping inflation you do see the prices
rising but the prices will continue to
rise your purchasing power will go slow
slowly slowly deteriorating and that's i
think the big issue right now is that
slow road to a useless dollar yeah well
financially we have to understand the
trends usually correlate with the
actions weeks and months from those
actions so what happens now is going to
correlate in the market in a few months
from now and that's why in the beginning
of covet i said hey the the major factor
here that's really going to hurt people
is going to be financial keep an eye on
the financial markets it's absolutely
crazy what's happening right now the u.s
national debt has just crossed over 29
trillion dollars and i believe tucker
carlson had a very good talking point
just a few days ago he said young people
don't have any possibility to have any
economic opportunity no opportunity for
any kind of mobility finding mobility
financially and that's why people are
going over to bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies and i think we are
seeing a transition for a lot of people
not trusting the financial markets
because how can you they're not playing
by any rules they're not playing by by
the math rules that are designed to that
specific
understanding of how
things work they're creating their own
rules they're just pressing zero on a
computer and giving it to their friends
meanwhile those zeros are having a real
life impact for everyone's purchases
every time you go to the supermarket you
see it you feel it and the average
person is having a harder and harder
time making ends meet and it's only
going to get worse from here from my
perspective difference between what we
have and what vymar germany had is it
they were burning dollars or deutsche
marks i think it was in wheelbarrows we
don't even have paper anymore it's all
digital so like if our currency goes
belly up we don't even have paper to
burn or cotton to burn at least they had
toilet paper at least the venezuelans
dry off well if you're cold outside and
you've got you know blankets of
carbon fuel of some sort yeah you can
keep yourself warm we just got a number
on a screen that you know doesn't do
anything for us i think that this
suppressing suppression this economic
suppression is driving people to
extremism in so many ways one of it is
is cryptocurrency it's an extreme
evolution of currency the other is
antifa this extreme street violence
people feeling
uh disincentive disincentivized or
whatever disenfranchised it's the right
word
so and they're they're they're lashing
out in different ways some people are
intelligently evolving the economy some
people are just smashing stuff up it
seems like it's all relative i really
think we reached a point where this kind
of financial calamity this kind of
destruction of our economic system is
almost done deliberately because if you
look at every action the government is
taking it's making it that much worse on
everyone else how can else house could
you explain giving the the military
industrial complex a 20 billion dollar
bonus when they didn't even ask for it
how can you explain just the reckless
spending how can you explain the build
back better bill how can you explain
raising taxes on everyone else is just
absolutely absurd to see
people's savings people's hard-earned
money that they worked their entire
lives for literally be eviscerated right
in front of them it's crazy but here's
the good news so tucker carlson talked
about how people millennials
gen even gen x gen z whatever the new
generation is that they're investing in
bitcoin because there's no ability to
save investing is very difficult
to trade and stay up to par with
inflation but the good news about
bitcoin is that it is a clearly superior
currency in my opinion the fact that
bitcoin has been discovered gives people
that exit route so you don't need to be
beholden to a two and a half trillion
dollar debt ceiling increase you can
save in bitcoin and bitcoin is a finite
asset it's free market money uh the most
sound money ever invented i think its
properties are completely superior to
golds in every sense you can debate gold
versus bitcoin and bitcoin beats it in
every single way so i think to add to
tucker's statement about people aren't
just
uh yes people are desperate to find a
way to hold on to their hard-earned
wealth but bitcoin also provides them an
exit and an actual superior currency to
the us dollar itself so that to me
that's the optimistic message is that
bitcoin can be a a protective off-ramp
to the chaos that's being
caused by these politicians and
bureaucrats in washington dc who don't
have any of our interests thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you